what's going on guys
Deadpool the trailer has officially
dropped know that grainy leaked Comic
Con footage so let's think about it you
like it you hate it we're gonna talk
about today with a pretty cool panel of
comic book and movie fans right here
right now first he is a writer for DC
Comics writes Batwoman Wonder Woman 77
many good titles under his belt more and
Draco welcome back thank you he'll do
the beer good to see you buddy Mike
Carlson is back hashtag Botanica Smike
how you live it I'm living great
excellent and this is his first time as
a guest on this show he's a writer for
honest trailers and an all-around swell
guy Spencer Gilbert
I have mark what you think of the
trailer um I honestly am NOT a Deadpool
fan I just have no connection with that
character I find the character a little
bit kind of smug and you're apathetic
towards him I'm apathetic towards
Deadpool but if it's good as I said on
your sister show movie fights if it's
good if I like it and I hope I do I
don't want to dislike any movie I will
appear both there and here dressed as
Deadpool you heard it here
lock it in write it down an ink Mike
Carlson - uh mark is really lukewarm on
this kind of cold what what do you think
all right I'll start with something I
like about it yeah okay something I like
about I think the action looks pretty
cool it's the stuff we saw in that
sizzle reel something I'm not so psyched
about is the jokes from 1999 posh spice
Rosie O'Donnell I know the script was
written a while ago but can they just
like sub in like some sort of different
pop star maybe instead of posh spice if
they were like hey watch out Kylie
Jenner or something like yeah watch out
cara delevingne
also we should mention this is a red
band trailer yes so it is raw
it is uncut you got f-bombs you got gore
Spencer what did you think I'm excited
with some reservations uh-huh I think
it's cool that we're getting in are
rated comic book movie I hope as well
just to encourage more things like
Suicide Squad or movies down the
pipeline to go with an r-rating and show
that they can carry that at box-office
wise the character Deadpool I also don't
have much of an attachment to from the
comics the jokes were a little Van
Wilder issue I'll dress
maybe left over from that they were
throwing so many on you that to me I'm
excited for like a feature-length
episode of Family Guy with a lot of
violence in it yeah that sounds like the
worst thing I'm also a little worried
the whole thing takes place on a bridge
I have a feeling that that shootout
that's going on in the bridge is just a
one scene in the movie but I could be
wrong be sure I cannot be sure a bridge
more um yeah from bridge I kind of like
what Spencer's alluding to it's not
trying to be anything we've seen right
now that's not that's not my issue with
it my I think what Mike said hits it on
the nail right on the head it just feels
very stale I mean a salt and pepper song
on the soundtrack to me taking that 90s
R&B song gave it some humor and some fun
flavor well if the movie said in 1995
will be perfect you don't have to be in
1995 to love old school jams Marc it did
kind of remind me of kick ass but I
liked kick ass well yeah the thing about
Deadpool is the first kick ass kicked
ass when he works in the comic books
there's and there have been a handful of
really good writers who really captured
that fourth-wall stuff and not made it
smug and annoying but it's hard to do
that from what the trailer looks like to
me it just looks like we're gonna have
two hours of Ryan Reynolds doing the
same Ryan Reynolds stick and that just
seems interminably painful
we've talked a little bit about the
trailer a lot of people might not be
very familiar with Deadpool especially
comic book readers let's fill them in a
little bit on the story of Deadpool so
he was a mercenary maybe I did Wilson
who had basically full body cancer yeah
I got a treatment that made him give him
almost Oh more than a Wolverine level
healing factor but yeah it's all lumpy
and tumor like yeah oh he's got he's
full of snark and yeah you say so his
healing powers more so than Wolverine
like in the comics he's been like
decapitated and had his head crushed and
it's regenerated and they tried to
justify the fourth wall stuff because
his brain is regenerating so fast that
it would drive anyone insane and it's
given him this heightened awareness and
in the classic early 90s like image
style he's got a lot of pouches and some
samurai swords and uses guns and looks
cool that's tiny feet I will say though
I will give props to Ryan Reynolds for
being committed to wearing the costume
in the mask so many of these superhero
movies the stars have to show their face
for a certain amount of time and the
fact that he has embraced the costume
and isn't afraid of the costume that's a
real growth in the in the
because we don't pay to see Robert
Downey jr. face we want to see armor and
the costume looks exactly like the comic
book that it might be the most faithful
costume ever done on screen so I will I
will definitely give them props for that
do you think this movie's going to have
a broader appeal or is going to be more
like Scott Pilgrim which what got huge
reaction from a tiny group of people
we'll see that's you know that's the
thing Canon Ryan Reynolds familiarity in
his appeal helped transcend this the
movie could be very profitable and very
successful it's just that we're alchemy
of comedy sometimes they cross over and
sometimes they don't I do feel like
maybe they're really like kind of niche
marketing cuz there's all those inside
jokes which again like 15 year-old boys
probably never saw or x-men origins
Wolverine you know what that is and they
don't know the movies rated R so 15 year
old boys technically aren't gonna be
able to see it mark but you know they'll
be bad and sneak in I have no sense of
how well this movie is going to do or
whether it makes sense to do these
financially but I hope it does well
enough to just encourage more experiment
taking in the superhero genre because if
we don't then we are going to be overrun
with superhero movies and they are going
to die out unless they keep taking
chances that's such a great point
Spencer because Marvel has set this tone
we know what we're getting from Marvel
more or less and it's good stuff I like
it DC has their darker tone which
they're exploring and you know I'm
hoping it's good this seemed to be on
its own path the more diversity of tone
we have in these comic book movies the
better because you know when you think
of a cop movie a cop movie could be
Serpico or Beverly Hills Cop yeah we
don't have that person or that breadth
of storytelling yet in the comic book
world we are those stories they exist in
the printed form but we haven't really
embraced them cinematically alright I'd
love to just get some final thoughts
from everybody let's go right down the
line I was underwhelmed by the trailer
but I will go into it with an open mind
and hope it's really great cool I'm
going to see it you've heard it there
haha and Spencer I'm excited with a few
reservations I'm gonna just stay away
from all trailers so I don't get any
more jokes foiled and go in opening day
there you go
I got kind of pumped over it what did
you think about the Deadpool red band
trailer let us know in the comments
section below
coolest comment ah we're gonna send you
a screen Dougie's t-shirt I want to
thank my awesome panel for coming in and
talking
about stuff good day mark and Draco
Mike Carlson Spencer Gilbert you guys
fun talking to you I'm how Rudnick
thanks for watching hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
here's one that really hurt to hate
because it's a sequel to a movie I
really like I loved Hot Tub Time Machine
one I saw it three times a week it came
out I saw that the drive-in I love oh
wow
I bet the drive-in makes any movie
better it kind of does except for me
beer oh thank you